[Applause]
[Music]
just before we get into the video today
do you want to say that I've recently
started a new channel it's called by
graphics we do long-form 20 minutes ish
biographies of people from history as
well as the present-day politicians but
a whole lot else please check out the
link in the description below and if you
like bio graphics please subscribe
anyway while everybody has their eyes on
North Korea another nuclear program
still worries those in the White House
that is the nuclear program of the
Islamic Republic of Iran this country
has such a bad reputation then when we
talk about it it can feel like we're
talking about one of those places that
only exists in the movies one of those
countries dominated by evil leaders who
dream of destroying the world well there
might actually be some truth to this but
definitely not as much as some seem to
think in fact Iran is not the most
religious it's not the most
authoritarian and it's not even the most
hostile place towards women in this part
of the world because we have Saudi
Arabia which is far far worse give you a
Iran it is a country of contradictions a
country whose government aims to work
under a democratic system but at the
same time everything is under the
control of one man
that man would be alley hominy the
supreme leader even though her first
glance isn't as scary as his predecessor
Ruhollah Khomeini who was scary just to
look at the truth is how many you can't
stand anything modern for him modernity
might as well have come from Satan
himself of the except for nuclear
technology of course
[Music]
that explains why in the past few years
Iran has been famous for two things
number one being one of the countries
alongside China where the most people
are executed every year and number two
wanting to build their own nuclear bomb
however unlike what has happens with the
North Korean crisis the US and Iran they
did reach an agreement in 2015 President
Obama led the joint comprehensive plan
of action and agreements to prevent Iran
from obtaining a nuclear bomb as in
agreements that many have considered to
be one of the greatest achievements in
all of foreign policy it's now more than
50 years since President Kennedy stood
before the American people and said let
us never negotiate out of fear but let
us never fear to negotiate
although to be fair all signs seemed to
point to the conclusion that this
agreement has not kept either party
satisfied
President of the United States now
Donald Trump is pretty clear about his
opinion on the deal ever since he was a
candidate he has described it as the
worst agreement ever negotiated during
his campaign Trump has vowed on many
many occasions that his top priority
would be to put an end to such a
catastrophic agreements I've been doing
deals for a long time I've been making
lots of wonderful deals great deals
that's what I do never ever ever in my
life have I seen any transaction so
incompetently negotiated as our deal
with Iran and do you not think that this
was the typical campaign message that
every politician repeats over over again
but then soon forgets about well once
the election has finished in his first
speech at the UN assembly Trump repeated
it loud and clear the Iran deal was one
of the worst and most one-sided
transactions the United States has ever
entered into frankly that deal is an
embarrassment to the United States and I
don't think you've heard the last of it
believe me they haven't done so yes but
it is true that both the presidents and
many other members of the Republican
Party loathe yes absolutely loathe
disagreements and they do so because
among other things agreements were also
signed with North Korea this is a good
deal for the United States North Korea
will freeze and then dismantle its
nuclear program South Korea and our
other allies will be better protected
and well these agreements they didn't
work at all except for allowing
Pyongyang to lay their hands on the bomb
well now you might be wondering why
exactly is it such a controversial
agreements well we're going to look at
that in a bit before we do let's take a
look at the context in which it was
signed
Iran a budding superpower
so during the Cold War it is said that
the Russians were so obsessed that they
saw a Chinese man behind every tree
something similar might now actually be
happening between Iran and the USA since
the Islamic Revolution of command-i in
1979 Iran has become one of Washington's
worst enemies it is accused Tehran of
being the first sponsor of radical and
anti-american groups like Hezbollah
Hamas or Fatah Labatt not mentioned
their support of the Syrian regime under
Bashar al-assad but there is more to
this Washington knows very well that
Iran it's not just any country
look Iran is absolutely huge it's got 80
million inhabitants and one of the
greatest amounts of mineral wealth on
earth and hey it's not just about oil
and natural gas here but it's also got
other minerals like copper iron zinc
uranium silver etc
[Music]
but yes we do all know that all other
natural gas spell they're particularly
important and that is why I now want to
ask you a question what is the biggest
fear of many analysts in Washington well
that is the son of Iraq and Iran
let me explain both countries their
neighbors have a majority Shiite rule
and influence of Tehran on Baghdad has
skyrocketed in the last few years we add
up the oil reserves of both countries
the amount is one of the largest in the
world it's larger than Saudi Arabia it's
larger than Venezuela
so coordinated international politics
between these two countries would result
in a superpower which is outside the
control of Washington with almost a
hundred and twenty million people and
that's not mentioning all of those other
natural resources this quite simply
would be an incredible amount of
influence so then what would happen if
Iran got a hold of a nuclear bomb now on
the one hand it would certainly
consolidate its role as an international
superpower as well as its influence over
its allies like Iraq but on the other
hand it would also trigger an arms race
with Saudi Arabia and the Emirates that
have already said they won't be left
behind if Tehran manages to get a
nuclear bomb and the result of all this
was pretty obvious it's tension it's
risk of proliferation it's risk of
nuclear disaster and also a loss of
American leverage in the area it goes
without saying that seeing such radical
governments in possession of such
powerful weapons or say doesn't make
anyone feel particularly safe well that
was the situation when the agreement was
reached back in 2015
[Music]
the deal
for years the United States is trying to
stop the nuclear program with financial
penalties that these were pretty done
useless didn't they hum the economy in
Iran well absolutely but they did
nothing to stop their nuclear program so
finally on November the 14th of July
2015 the nuclear deal it was signed an
agreement with a clear target to prevent
proliferation and make sure Iran only
uses nuclear technology for peaceful
purposes however since then the deal it
has suffered harsh attacks we're going
to have a look at some of the reasons
cited by critics of this agreement but
first I think now is a good time to
think about the circumstances under
which this agreement was signed and the
first thing we need to note is that the
nuclear program in Iran is very very
advanced according to US intelligence if
the agreement was to be broken Iran
could develop its first nuclear bomb in
a matter of months this is the way it is
today 2017 and it was even truer back in
2015 when the Iranian program was
working on its fullest capacity that is
why I want to take a moment to think
about three possible outcomes here war
agreements or Iran with nuclear
capability
so stopping the nuclear program with
military intervention it would not have
been an easy task it would have resulted
in many victims the cost for the u.s.
would have been prohibitive and the u.s.
who have had to keep in military
intervention in the Middle East for
decades to compare it is estimated that
this would be the Iraq war multiplied by
five because I mean it's one thing to
destroy infrastructure and it's a very
different thing to eliminate the
knowledge that a country has to make
nuclear bombs Obama knew that this
situation was totally impossible what he
wanted was to get away from the Middle
East and not get into any more trouble
in this region because it's been
something of a chronic nightmare for the
United States but sure on the other
hands not doing anything would have
meant that Iran we've got in their new
time and as we have seen it would have
resulted in an arms race in the region
which Washington didn't want either so
an agreement it was the only option left
I mean we make a deal meant everyone's
happy right just wait there a second
because despite that many experts
especially your Republicans don't even
want to hear about this pact this is a
bad deal Obama broke every rule of
negotiation we get an agreement a very
questionable value if I am elected
president on the very first day in
office I will rip to shreds this
catastrophic Iranian nuclear deal what
the Iranians have been given a blank
cheque basically by by the president
invited States so I think all just war
hawks determined to impose their ideas
by force well maybe there are some like
that but the truth is they also have a
point they say and they are right that
the u.s. already signs many agreements
with North Korea and Pyongyang never
kept its words which is why North Korea
is now a nuclear power they are
convinced that Iran will do the same and
there is no better evidence than the
facts that Iran has not stopped their
ballistic missile program Iran is
boosting its missile capabilities in
order to increase the accuracy precision
and range Iran will not stop its missile
projects and this program what is being
developed with North Korean technology
so it seems clear which way a deal with
Iran will go
we cannot let a murderous regime
continue these destabilizing activities
while building dangerous missiles and we
cannot abide by an agreement if it
provides cover for the eventual
construction of a nuclear program
besides since the pact has a limited
duration Iran could still put itself in
a position to get its arsenal the moment
the deal is over and it could be armed
within a matter of months however as we
have seen the alternatives they're
really not any better
do they want Iran doesn't necessarily
need to go the way of North Korea
you're on benefits of the agreement I'm
pretty sure many of you are thinking
that comparing North Korea and Iran is
easy after all both countries are
radical dictatorships right well I mean
not really to be third thinks they're
quite a bit different Iranian society is
much more open-minded than North Korean
society in Iran there is a well formed
middle class there are political debates
and things like having a smartphone and
access to the Internet
it's really quite common in fact most
Iranians especially the younger
generation are clearly Pro agreement you
see it's not just a matter of
international politics it's also a
matter of quality of life the penalty is
put in place by the international
community
they were very damaging for Iran
look in 2013 when President
Ahmadinejad's the main defender of the
agreements left power the economy of
Iran it was devastated for an investment
vanished
the unemployment rate skyrocketed
inflation grew to around 40% and
expectations for improvement weren't
high in short it was a complete mess but
thanks to the agreement the penalties
that started to disappear and since then
oil exports have tripled
I mean Iraq it's not North Korea they
need the trade and the economic
advantages that this Agreement has
brought the joint comprehensive plan of
action will produce the comprehensive
lifting of all UN Security Council
sanctions as well as multilateral and
national sanctions related to Iran's
nuclear program including steps on
access in areas of trade technology
finance and energy the Obama's
administration was that with a more
prosperous and trade open Iran the
younger more open-minded generation
would be allowed to take power in a few
years however those who oppose the
agreements argue it's necessary to be
more demanding with Iran because
otherwise it will eventually become
another North Korea and new nuclear
power anyway it's not an easy situation
as you can see but truth be told I think
it would be a mistake to think that any
pact is bad until proven otherwise
having to run under pressure might be a
good strategy for let's be careful not
to go too far we could all lose well now
it's your turn if you were the President
of the United States what do you think
you would do with Iran would you make a
deal what leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I do really hope that you enjoyed
this video if you did please do not
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos every Monday and every
Thursday and don't forget to check out
our friends of the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and well if
you're looking for something else to
watch please do check out my brand new
channel biographic there's a link in the
description below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]